>> In the same way that our genomes influence traits like eye color, hair
color, or susceptibility to cancer even, they
can also influence our ability to metabolize drugs.
>> Like alcohol. A drug is defined as any chemical that when introduced
into the body, can influence biological processes.
This includes things like alcohol, even caffeine.
Now, we have a very special experiment set up for all you Udacious
students out there today. This is Lauren, you know Lauren. And this is Jennie.
>> Hi, I'm Jennie.
>> And they're going to represent how two people with two different genomes
can metabolize a drug differently. A drug like alcohol. Now, they're about the
same height. They're about the same size. And we might expect them to
have the same tolerance. But let's see
what happens when they finish their drinks.
>> Cheers.
[MUSIC]
>> Alright, Lauren and Jenny happen to be above the
age of 21, which is the legal drinking limit in the United States. Neither of
them drove to work today. And because they're responsible with alcohol, they
actually didn't finish their drinks. So, let's see. How do you feel ladies?
>> I feel okay.
>> And what about you, Jenny?
>> I feel amazing.
>> You do?
>> I do.
>> You look a little you look a little red to me.
>> Yeah, it's a little warm in here, isn't it?
>> not really. I can see in your cheeks,
though, you've got some you've got some redness there.
>> Hm.
>> Does that normally happen when you drink.
>> Yes.
>> that's what we call alcohol flush reaction, sort of
that, that redness in your cheeks that, that I see there.
>> Yeah, and I see a little bit on your chest as well.
>> Hm. Yeah.
>> And so that normally
happens when you drink, huh?
>> Yes it does.
>> does it run in your family?
>> Well my dad actually is allergic to alcohol and gets hives.
>> Oh my gosh. Well the alcohol flush
reaction is known to be prevalent in those of
an Asian background. So, I'd like to know
from you, do you have the alcohol flush reaction?